[Música]
muchas gracias así como alejandro decía
que su reto era hacer que los abogados
entendieran pues creo que el mío es que
soy abogada es hacer que los ingenieros
y todo el resto también entienda este
tema tan complejo que es la gestión de
derechos que es la gestión de derechos
quiero empezar esta charla con un
misterio el misterio de obras literarias
de obras literarias universales nadie
sabe en este momento después de muchos
siglos de investigación nadie sabe quién
escribió las mil y una noches' nadie
sabe quién lo escribió nadie sabe dónde
se escribió ni exactamente cuándo se
escribió
lo que sí se sabe es que los que vieron
muchas personas por analizando el texto
y los modismos y la forma en que se
escribe pueden saber que son muchas
personas se sabe teniendo en cuenta que
son muchos textos que hay varias
versiones que se escribió a través de
casi ocho ciclos desde el siglo octavo
hasta el siglo casi quince se termina de
escribir lo que hoy conocemos como las
mil y una noches' y que se escribió en
muchísimos territorios lo que hoy era lo
que antes era persia y hoy es irán
afganistán irak etcétera todos conocemos
las mil y una noches' consideramos lo
hayamos leído o no conocemos a simbad el
marino
aladino disney se ha lucrado muchísimo
de aladino por supuesto conocemos a alí
babá y los 40 ladrones conocemos muchas
cosas a sherezada sabemos que son las
mil y una noches'
quiero comenzar esta charla diciéndoles
que hoy en día con el actual sistema de
gestión de derechos de autor que existe
yo creo que una obra como las mil y una
noches' sería imposible de crear o por
lo menos sería muy difícil de crear bajo
el sistema actual de gestión y de
derechos y quiero explicarles por qué
y para eso quiero ponerle un poco
solamente en contexto de lo que ha sido
la evolución de derechos de autor todos
ustedes que trabajan en industrias de
contenidos de propiedad intelectual
tienen un con algún contacto pero quiero
contarles que eso no ha sido estático es
una nación y ha estado siempre con
nosotros en el mundo el derecho de autor
no surge sino más o menos cuando ya
existe la imprenta cuando guttenberg
empieza a crear las copias y dice
podemos crear una copia de un manuscrito
antes de eso eran los copistas por allá
en el ministeri en los monasterios en
las abadías que se demoraban a años
copiando cada uno de los libros con la
imprenta eso ocurre rapidísimo y dicen
bueno en venecia y más o menos en el
siglo 15 dicen vamos a crearle un
privilegio que solo los editores y
ciertos editores puedan crear copias de
esos libros ahí nace el copyright
derecho de la copia inicialmente solo
para los libros pero de ese momento
hasta hoy el siglo 21 se han creado
muchísimos más derechos que ustedes
también conocen después dijeron nombres
que la música también
las canciones también merecen protección
después dijeron no es que las
grabaciones de las canciones también
merecen protección y los productos
productores fonográficos después con la
industria del cine que lastimosamente se
nos fue de claudia pero la industria del
cine también dice en un minuto
el productor cinematográfico y después
series televisión el productor
audiovisual cierto dicen también no pero
es que hay otra gente que aporta mucho
esa propia intelectual que está los
actores como cómo hacen para para que se
vea de verdad una obra una obra
literaria deseen démosles nuevos
derechos también a los actores a los
músicos a los intérpretes recientemente
dicen no es que también los guionistas
se merecen unos derechos adicionales los
directores los actores todo el mundo
empieza y en la evolución del derecho de
autor empieza cada día hay más derechos
más sujetos de autor y adicionalmente
más tipos de derechos el principio era
bueno que se pueda copiar o que no se
pueda copiar después dice no pero que
también se pueda oír en público que no
se pueda oír en público después no que
también sean dueños de sí se puede
no se puede modificar esa canción esa
obra esa obra de teatro entonces poco a
poco empieza esa gestión de derechos a
volverse mucho más compleja existen
muchos derechos los mismos autores los
titulares tienen muchas cosas y no saben
qué hacer con ellas nace así lo que se
llama la gestión de los derechos de
autor cómo se administran cuál es la
forma en que esos titulares ya sean los
autores o los intérpretes quien sea
dueño de sus derechos como los maneja y
quiero rápidamente darles una visión de
la complejidad que es ese mundo que
pueda hacer un autor con sus derechos
básicamente lo que quiera los puede
dividir infinitamente una particularidad
de los derechos de autor es que son casi
que infinitamente divisibles son
divisibles por su naturaleza eso quiere
decir que un autor o un titular puede
decir si yo te autorizo el derecho de
copia que tú puedas copiar en mi libro
pero solamente en un territorio y ese
territorio puede ser colombia puede ser
latino américa o puede ser bogotá
ser chico o puede ser este lugar lo
mismo con las obras musicales puede
decir uno no yo quiero solamente ciertos
medios televisión pero no todo
televisión quiero solamente televisión
abierta o televisión cerrada pero no
solamente televisión serra quiero
restringirlo a televisión lineal la
televisión que solamente pase de corrido
y esa es la naturaleza del derecho de
autor además puedo decir por cuánto
plazo quiero por cinco años por la
eternidad por lo que sea
esto genera un panorama muy complejo y
muy difícil de manejar como hacen esos
titulares para negociar para administrar
esos derechos y surgen entonces las
formas de hacer esa gestión y hay
diversas formas de hacerlo que existe la
más digamos la natural que sería la
gestión directa o la gestión individual
cada uno el dueño de su derecho va y
negocia con el que quiere usar su
derecho si alguien quiere comprar millón
para hacer una película yo negocio con
ese productor alguien quiere usar mi
software yo voy y quien quiera usar mi
software le doy una licencia cierto se
sería la negociación directa pero
piensen que hay muchas circunstancias en
que esa negociación directa es
ineficiente costosísima de un alto costo
de monitoreo y absolutamente casi que se
gasta sale más caro el collar que el
perro sale más caro yo ir a cada uno de
los restaurantes hasta cada uno de los
establecimientos de comercio a decir
buenas acá me han oído en mi canción
cuántas veces durante el último mes ha
bueno son 500 pesos ya me costó
que el bus para llevarme al
establecimiento de comercio surge
entonces otro tipo de gestión un poco
más eficiente la gestión colectiva surge
además muy inter de manera muy
interesante en francia- que cuando
llegan unos unos compositores a un
restaurante y oyen su canción dicen como
así aquí no me están pagando nada por
esta canción que yo estoy oyendo desde
ese señor hombros que yo no tengo que
pagar nada ese radio entonces no lo va a
pagar la comida que me estoy comiendo y
ahí surge gana en esa pelea los
compositores y surge la gestión
colectiva en francia- más o menos en los
y la gestión colectiva la llevan
normalmente las organizaciones que
ustedes conocen como sociedades de
gestión colectiva sayco acinpro
promúsica en eeuu hasta bien etcétera
pero no necesariamente esas son las
únicas que lo llevan a veces los mismos
titulares se agrupan y acuden por
ejemplo que es la asociación colombiana
de lectoras musicales en eeuu han creado
una agencia para que otorgue licencias
es tan complejo el mundo que pues se
necesita lograr economías de escala que
produce esto
y creo que trae algo 'creative commons'
a propósito que claramente lo describe
aunque ahorita pensaba que de pronto
unos espaguetis sería algo un poco más
apropiado realmente genera un mundo muy
complejo
y súmele es la internet internet que no
tiene barreras que está en todos los
territorios que para todos los tipos de
uso que no es claro cuando es privado
cuando es público etcétera realmente
genera algo muy complejo de manejar para
quienes tanto para los autores como para
pero sobre todo para los usuarios de ese
contenido y de esos contenidos qué
consecuencias trae eso para la creación
del contenido y ahorita vamos a hablar
de la protección del contenido porque es
claro por ejemplo que los medios tienen
esa doble calidad no los medios son
usuarios de contenido pero a la vez son
productores de contenido entonces están
en las dos puntas cuál es la
consecuencia que trae esa complejidad y
realmente cuando uno está en ese mundo
tan complejo no sabe a quién pedirle
autorización no sabe quién la tiene
a veces ocurre que no se sabe quién
tiene los derechos y empiezan a dejar de
utilizar cosas a dejarse ver a referir a
eventos a contenido con el que no se
siente seguro y que sus abogados le
decimos no eso no nos han dado el
certificado derechos de autor con mejor
no lo use que produce es un enfriamiento
de la libertad de expresión en el fondo
eso lleva a que uno deje de usar
libremente una cantidad y deje de
expresar muchísimas ideas creaciones que
podría ser de otra manera el copyleft en
este en este marco y el copyleft no
solamente como lo describe muy bien
alejandro o creative commons en general
las licencias establecidas
preestablecidas entran a solucionar un
poco este tema de algunos autores que
dicen mire yo no quiero que me vengan
molestando
yo quiero que todo el mundo lo use aquí
declaro que quiero que todo el mundo lo
use que quiero que todo el mundo lo use
pero que diga que yo fui y que me den el
crédito y que no lo usen comercial para
eso existen licencias preestablecidas
eso entra a solucionar de alguna manera
la situación
pues yo creo que funciona muy bien pero
en otro tipo de contenidos
no tanto uno mira y si vieran lo que
mejor encontrando la foto del sancocho
no que tuviera creative commons porque
si no pues no lo poder el lujo de sacar
aquí algo sin licencia y shutterstock
como que no tiene muchas fotos de
sancocho entonces realmente sí aunque es
una salida todavía le falta hay que hay
que fortalecerlo y hay que tener más
contenidos sobre eso cuál es la
situación en colombia y creo que hoy
pensaba que la charla de alejandro es
muy
muy inspiradora la mía es un poco más de
queja pero vamos a buscar una solución y
es cuál es la situación en colombia
tenemos varios problemas incluso tenemos
una solución pero que no hemos podido
implementar primero yo creo que la más
grave es que en colombia existe una
grave tensión entre la gestión
individual y la gestión colectiva
hablábamos de la gestión colectiva es la
que hacen cuando yo
es solamente sayco acinpro hubo
solamente una persona la que baic ahora
a todos los establecimientos de comercio
atado a las discotecas etcétera
nuestra corte constitucional hace unos
diez años analizó el tema y dijo que no
que esa esa gestión colectiva no podía
ser obligatoria que tenía que ser
optativa debido al derecho asociación
nuestra constitución dice que tenemos el
derecho de hacerlo o no y si alguien no
quiere asociarse a la gestión colectiva
pues no lo debiera hacer entonces desde
hace 10 años tenemos la posibilidad de
que cada uno de los autores vaya a cada
uno de los establecimientos de comercio
a cada uno de los medios cadenas de
radio televisión donde sea que se haga
comunicación pública puede ir a decir
durante los últimos diez años usted ha
sonado mi canción
a veces me hace el favor y me da por
favor 10 mil millones de pesos así son y
entonces que genera una gran tensión
entre esos dos derechos seguramente el
derecho de asociación y por supuesto lo
que es la seguridad jurídica sobre todo
de los negocios y en general de el
comercio
otra particularidad son los nuevos
derechos en los últimos años ustedes
saben que se han creado incluso nuevos
derechos los guionistas tienen nuevos
derechos los directores le y pepe
sánchez pepe sánchez
los actores ley fanny mikey no todo eso
son cosas que derechos adicionales que
tienen que pagar sobre todo quienes los
medios tradicionales inicialmente por lo
menos que son a los que van ellos a
cobrar esos derechos cuando hace unos
años unos 10 años solamente sayco y
acinpro cobraban listo y llegaron
algunos acuerdos un porcentaje de
nuestros ingresos es lo que pagaremos
pero si ahora aparecen actores
guionistas directores y en el fut en
europa en incluso existe ya otro derecho
de los editores digitales pues esa torta
que antes había que compartir con unos
pocos pues hay que compartir con todavía
más y si a eso pensamos que la torta por
las circunstancias que todos conocemos
la torta global va disminuyendo pues
creo que se genera una una dificultad en
el negocio un incremento de los costos
sin duda pero también un incremento muy
rápido de esos costos y eso
súmenle a eso la gestión individual de
la gente que va y pide específicamente
sus derechos
otro problema que tenemos en colombia
pero para hacerles sinceros tenemos en
todas partes del mundo en muchas partes
del mundo es el problema de las obras
huérfanas de hecho le dicen muy
dramáticamente la tragedia de las obras
huérfanas y si es una tragedia piensen
ustedes la cantidad de contenidos que
hoy en día no sabemos de quién son
muchos obras literarias para qué pasa
muchísimo están en las bibliotecas una
obras unas obras hermosas pero no
sabemos dónde está el autor puede que
sepamos quién es oa veces es anónimo
pero entonces no le podemos pedir
autorización para difundir diseminar su
obra para difundirla se queda esa obra
guardada
eso pasa dramáticamente con las
fotografías porque las fotografías no se
sabe de quién son hay unos archivos
hermosos de una cantidad de fotografías
es de los últimos años que todavía no
están en el dominio público y que no
pueden ser usadas no pueden ser
mostradas lo que son obviamente tienen
un valor cultural altísimo y no puede
ser eso es lo que se llama la tragedia
de las obras webs en otros países se ha
logrado solucionar diciendo por ejemplo
hay unas licencias obligatorias si usted
ya hizo el esfuerzo de contactar a la
persona y no la encontró bueno para que
no saque unos centavitos y aquí nosotros
lo guardamos
úselo no sé lo que es lo importante si
es que se pueda difundir el contenido y
lo último es una solución pero se ha
empezado a convertir un problema porque
no sé no se ha implementado desde hace
muchos años ya la ley trae la
día 1 la obligación del mandato de crear
lo que se llama una ventanilla única y
que uno no tenga que ir a 700 sociedades
de gestión colectiva a 800 personas que
hacen su gestión individual sino que
puede ir uno a una sola tienda y puede
decir yo pago mis derechos de autor uso
todo lo que uso lo uso bien pero pago
solamente una vez con una negociación y
la 'ventanilla única' verá también cómo
lo arregla internamente ese mandato está
desde hace varios años pero
desafortunadamente no se ha podido
implementar haría yo un llamado a que
eso es un tema muy importante y creo que
solucionaría en gran medida muchos de
los problemas prácticos que genera en
este momento la gestión colectiva para
terminar cuál es la solución que creo
que ya me quejé no me quede un poco y la
idea es dar soluciones yo creo que las
soluciones son algo de regulación mucha
tecnología y cambio de mentalidad
algo de regulación se necesita que el
estado algo diga que des articula esa
tensión que existe entre la gestión
colectiva la gestión individual que
solucione ese problema que están
teniendo en este momento los medios de
enfrentarse a una cantidad de nuevos
costos que antes no tenía y por supuesto
hay que adaptarse no quiere decir que no
haya que pagar los derechos de autor
pero hay que hacerlo en condiciones de
mercado en condiciones claras
transparentes etcétera entonces el
estado algo debe poder regular sobre la
materia segundo tecnología
la tecnología es una maravilla ya existe
tecnología ya que mediante atmós
algoritmos y block change
ya puede decir exactamente esta canción
ha sonado 500 veces en spotify de la
caja negra le llaman la caja negra el
cálculo que hace spotify le corresponden
a natalia barrera que es la cantante
tanta plata y me entra directamente a mi
billetera electrónica una maravilla se
ahorra uno el intermediario se ahorrará
uno todo el mundo se pagaron los
derechos de autor pero por último
también un cambio de mentalidad y creo
que es un cambio de mentalidad de todos
de la industria pero también de los
autores de los autora listas que llaman
porque estamos en una época muy distinta
así en la época del contenido de la
propiedad intelectual pero regla de
economía básica a mayor oferta
a menor precio y eso hay que tenerlo en
cuenta ciertamente hay varios que son
especiales pero hay mucho contenido y lo
que antes por ejemplo una disquera
esperaba a recibir por hoy yo me acuerdo
cuando fui a comprar carísimo el primer
sidibé de new kids on the block me llevo
mi papá a sanandresito en esa época pero
lo compramos original y era una cosa yo
me acuerdo que sea no puede ser todo lo
que le costó a mi papá eso sí dice eran
carísimos hoy en día lo que puede llegar
a recibir un autor por una canción que
suena en spotify pues pueden ser
centavos pero ahora ya no está vendiendo
una canción está esperando recibir esas
zonas de 500 mil sonadas que ojalá pueda
llegar a tener en todo el resto del
mundo pero ciertamente es un cambio de
mentalidad hay que ver cómo se modifica
ese esa forma de pensar es que creo que
viene de todos de los autores pero
también de los medios y de los que
usamos el contenido
creo que con esa solución esperaría uno
que pudiera solucionarse el grave
problema que dejaría a las mil y una
noches' y hoy se quisieran crear
imagínense si uno quisiera un editó
ustedes creen que un editor se le mete
se le mediría a crear las editar las mil
y una noches' no ya el gerente estaría
diciéndole y el abogado al que se le
ocurrió la idea pero incluso se le
ocurre con una cantidad de autores que
nadie sabe quiénes son que en 2000
territorios con distintas legislaciones
con una cantidad de leyes que además
cambian cada año no no no yo mejor no
creo las mil y una noches' entonces creo
que tenemos que crear ese ambiente en el
que la creación de obras complejas que
requieren de muchos autores de
colaboración pueda ser creada con más
facilidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]